hey what's up guys my name is a cello
and lapses is a series that i am doing
for machinimarealm it's a minecraft
series it's minecraft machinima series
so basically right it's got kind of like
the story of lost but it's actually very
different if you guys just don't want to
hear me talk we just want to go see what
it is for yourselves then there is a
link in the description and that is the
tech that's like the trailer teaser it's
not really the trailer is just like a
teaser for the actual series which is
going to come out on febru 22nd 2013 and
if you actually click the link in the in
the description you guys can actually
see the teaser on machinima realms
channel so um definitely go check that
out leave a like leave a comment let me
know what you guys think on that video
give it a favorite if you if you really
liked it because this series is going to
be freaking awesome I'm really excited
I'm really happy to have the opportunity
to actually do this I don't want to get
too in depth to the actual story of the
series its massive though like tons of
hours of work is getting put into this
it's just going to be it's just going to
be the best thing ever so I'm definitely
make sure that you guys stay tuned for
that and I'll give you guys more details
as it comes out but again you know I'm
going to try and keep my mouth shut
because um I definitely don't want to
ruin your guys experience but basically
season one starts on februari 22nd on
machinima realms channel so if you guys
aren't subscribed to missionary realm go
ahead and do that again if you guys
don't want to risk is you know they do
upload like three videos a day you guys
don't want to be like bombarded with all
those videos you can stay subscribe to
this one but what I recommend you guys
do is subscribe to my gaming channel and
that's usually booked on force after
them mr. cherno because I'll be
announcing every episode on that channel
definitely i'll probably be giving like
a director's commentary as well so on
that's the best way to sort of stay in
touch with this series but season one
starts februari 22nd and there's going
to be 16 episodes in season one and it's
basically going to be one a week
starting on februari 22nd so I'm again
you know the teaser the link to the
teaser is in the description make sure
to click on that check it out and again
you know give that video over there on
their channel I like favorite comment
saying like Jonas
you or whatever or give me your thoughts
on what you what you thought and yeah
i'll see i'll see you guys there later
guys